[Music]
my movie and this is my life Vanity
Fair's famous Hollywood Issue removes a
famous face actor James Franco was cut
out from the annual cover which features
Oprah Winfrey Nicole Kidman Reese
Witherspoon Tom Hanks and many more this
year the mag tells ET the 39 year old
was edited out because of allegations of
misconduct on January 11th the Los
Angeles Times published an article
featuring the accounts of five women
accusing Franco of inappropriate
behavior and abuse of power
just days before that Franco had
addressed rumors of misconduct that were
swirling on social media the things that
I heard that were on Twitter are not
accurate if I've done something wrong I
will fix it I have to since then he
stayed relatively quiet there was
sourced fooled et he was quote not in a
good place
after all the allegations and is quote
genuinely remorseful this was set to be
a major awards season for the star after
his movie the disaster artist aimed rave
reviews he won the Best Actor Golden
Globe while wearing a times up pen
earlier this week Oscar nominations were
announced and he did not receive one I
have my own side of this story but I
believe in you know these people that
have been underrepresented getting their
stories out enough that I will you know
hold back things that I could sage